i don't know it just feels i i feel bad
for the people who
physically like can't control their
gambling yeah i mean i i i i i should
be playing but they should not be
playing games like this and i feel like
i feel like these games should really
come with a warning tell that to take
time yeah
yeah exactly it should come there should
be like heavy warnings
and games i think to like say hey listen
you can spend a grand
and come out with pngs like what was
that were you looking at guys
so they're just full off okay sorry this
should be like a heavy warning saying
listen you can
spend a grand for like an animation and
a png that gets you a little bit of
serotonin like that's it like no money
involved
like gambling totally fair that it's
like well i just it
i yeah i it angers me so much how like
you just you just don't see the value in
those people i mean that's that's just a
new generation right
what would you want to pay for do you
want to pay for more money no i'll pay
for a little bit of serotonin people
don't
like often you never hit people like
defending gambling odds right they're
just like yeah dude
it's what it is gambling's what it is
and you go in there and it's [ __ ] and
yeah if you want to go and waste your
house always
going where you want it yeah but but
gotcha everyone's like oh no actually
like it's everyone's like i guess
because the option there is free to play
yeah but because there's there's no
free-to-play play gambling option right
yeah well actually some
sometimes will like give you free drinks
so just turn up get a free drink let's
go
i guess that's the equivalent of free to
play right yeah yeah yeah i have an
orange juice please
no gambling that's the equivalent of
like free temple today
yeah and they are generous but i guess
people if you don't have a gambling
addiction you can't understand how it
feels to have a gambling addiction
yeah yeah exactly and i get it why some
people might just want to play a game
don't know that it has like gambling in
it maybe yeah essentially and then they
get like kind of track
tricked into it because they've been
weaned on the game and then that's
that's just
modern apps though because because we've
just found a way to literally
hack our brains like human being we're
like we we like to think that we're not
predictable right
but how how of like five ten years ago
can you imagine like just
like having most of your life have most
of my life now is scrolling down on
something
yes you know what i mean most of my life
when i'm not talking to you guys i'm
scrolling down on some kind of [ __ ]
timeline yeah yeah
it's never-ending philosophical stuff
here yeah yeah but back to the point
of gadget right the other thing that
we've done is that we've done the best
thing that we could
ever want for these companies we've
memed spending money
yeah we've cause every nobody wants to
feel bad for wasting 200
and not getting what they want so what
do you do you go to twitter you tweet
out how you didn't get anything and you
may
pick like the pain pekka whatever it's
called
that is that is a pog champ right there
son that is very important i'm not a
boomer
oh god stop meaning about me being a
boomer for one second listen
we have all like tricked each other into
making gambling like a community event
and like like enjoying it yeah because
because no one wants to lose alone
because we share the pain right we share
we share the pain pick up yeah
we've done what exactly what these
companies [ __ ] wanted us to do yeah
which is
make like the gambling into like a form
of acceptance
like you're not truly
unless you [ __ ] gather a thousand
bucks and haven't got the one with thick
thighs
you forget about three months later [ __ ]
no are you telling me
that part of like the gambling
experience like you go into a casino i
remember the last time i went to casino
with you
great time because you got to you
[ __ ] egged on eugene to like lose his
money
and he thought he was [ __ ] hilarious
that was funny so you eugenes are
friends um so you basically did the
exact same thing yeah
what happened was that i you know at the
time he didn't have a job
and we were telling him you know you
probably shouldn't be spending your
money yes but
i was like you know i kept playing i
didn't lose much like 100 bucks yeah and
i
i was planning that much and he wanted
to keep up with me and i was like if you
want to you can go ahead and
i don't have to do it i don't know man
that sounds very suggestive to me
like i'm gonna guess psychology
it's like it's like i'm gonna do a
temple i mean you don't know you don't
have to do it i just i mean you know i
mean
whatever right whatever all right i'm
not sitting
i'm not streaming me going to a casino
and being like hey guys it's [ __ ]
gambling blackjack
hog man got blackjack you know it's the
equivalent
i mean it is the equivalent of that i
mean it is
i mean like i said gotcha is a wi-fi you
can see you know stream gambling is that
there's poker i know yeah there's a
black jack can you is that there's
pretty heavy rules around it though
yeah probably but there's not heavy
rules around gacha no
i guess why not why not should that be
should they be
honestly should be i think there should
be some regulations i i feel like
the biggest thing about gacha is that
people should know what they're getting
themselves into
um people should know a lot of things
that's why that's why people should
also have the option to tell casinos hey
can you ban me because i have no
self-control
there's no way to do that with gotcha
and unfortunately unlike this is that is
that an option with casinos
yeah in every country you can do that
you can you can basically
so what you're saying is we need to come
up with like the gasha police
i am dead seriously there should be
something on the like play store or
something that you can be like listen
i gamble too much can you please not
allow me to spend more than like
100 bucks like a year or something like
set a hard limit that there's no way to
turn off
i i i agree with you with that because
because if you go to the casinos you
fill out the form and says
please ban me from this casino they will
never let you in ever
like because they have like a database
and a lot of the time if you
uh i think sometimes some courts require
you to do it for certain occasions but
it's very popular and common that people
who gamble too much but they want to get
their life on track
you know because it's it's easy to have
a lapse in like willpower
and you go to the casino yeah so if 95
of the time you're like i'm never
gambling basically just chastity build
themselves right basically
you can say like this is not good for me
i'm going to fill out a form
i didn't know you could do that yeah
yeah in the uk 100 uh because it's
gambling's like a huge problem in the uk
for like betting shops and stuff so
yeah they'll they'll do it and you can
basically if it's a chain as well
they'll ban you from every chain
and they'll have that but like i do i do
think you're talking about uh
like a vast minority because like most
the people who i've met
who have who are playing gacha games
they've they're not like
no no they're not like us right but for
us it's kind of like
like for me at least you know it's it's
kind of like it kind of revolves around
my job you know what i mean you stream
you stream you do it it gets views right
yeah exactly but like for most people
that
i know that play gotcha they haven't
spent like an inordinate amount of money
on it but like i don't think there
should be an ability
to ruin your [ __ ] life for pulling
anime girls
because like we know uh techtone who's a
popular uh gacha game streamer yeah and
at one point
he used to play what was it um
summoner's war
he nearly like i think he went homeless
right he legit went like finance he like
i think he might have
filed for bankruptcy something yeah he
went fully broke from gacha games yeah
gosh this should never be a thing that
should never remember him telling me
that like it was like a [ __ ] like
story that should never be a thing for
casinos either right
no but i mean there's more i agree there
should be more regulations about it
there needs to be a gotcha police